one of our favorite green bay packers uh
he was he was on this show and he was
just a
a rookie and now look at him he's got a
new contract and he's got uh
that in his back pocket as he joins us
here on the rich eisen show aaron jones
of the green bay packers how are you
aaron
i'm doing good at you i'm better for
talking to you how is showtime
underscore 33 doing in the middle of may
right now uh been doing all right you
know just get back got
getting back to the grind uh stack back
in the days and
um just trying to be successful what was
free agency like for you i assume that
was a first for you
right obviously uh it definitely was a
first for me
um just kind of shocked you know um
never been that position before not
knowing where i'm going to end up
playing football
if i'm going to have to pick up and move
across country or what it may be but
i'm glad i got to stay at packer and
stay at cheesehead
well i mean the way it worked it seemed
like you know the team
you and the team were gonna move on
right
and then if i'm not mistaken the timing
of it did you sign
after the new league year opened i mean
how
how did that work because there was like
a 24-hour period where i thought are you
kidding
me they're not going to keep him uh or
was just that the way that the news
cycle went is was there a moment where
you thought that that was
it was over in green bay for you um
definitely i mean after the season i i
definitely
thought it was probably over up until um
i would say right right when i was
talking to
you know um my drew my agent had called
me
and he had mentioned that the packers
were still
still wanting me to come back and still
interested in me you know and i
love the system i feel like i'm a fit in
the system
uh know the players there i mean i have
my home there
and so just you know everything felt
right and um
so i'm i'm glad i was able to stay there
and uh they wanted me back
well i mean part of the reason why i'm
kicking the tires on this portion of our
conversation aaron jones is because
you know the the the front office of the
green bay packers and how they go about
their business and do their business in
roster building and
winning now or winning for the future or
playing for the future is definitely
front and centers i'm sure
you are very well aware um
did you have any contact with aaron
rodgers during your free agency period
where he was
checking in on you or anything like that
i don't know what the nature of your
relationship is but i just figured i'd
ask that question uh
he checked on me seeing how how i was
doing it and um
i i texted him letting him know that i
was coming back and uh
him and tay and uh david and mercedes
they were all
excited i let them know before i get it
broke um
and all of my guys all my leaders they
were excited for me and
um congratulating me so um
what is uh your sense on what is going
on with aaron rodgers
and the packers right now um
i mean i'm just sitting back i mean i
see what everybody else sees i mean i
haven't
heard from aaron or anybody so i'm just
i'm gonna wait till
i get up to green bay and see for myself
or hear
hear it from him myself you know it's
just um
i don't get caught up in the reading
articles and things like that
um i'll just wait until it plays out and
control what i can control
so how how much time did
jordan love get on the practice field
last year can you take me into that
front row seat did he get
much time at all in aaron's mvp season
oh yes sir i mean we um he played
he ran a scout team and um
he was working with me every saturday i
mean we're
doing over the shoulder ball drills
different things like that so jordan did
get a
get a lot of work i mean and then they
have we have periods every day where
um there we have individual peers where
they're working with us and
working on our development every day how
is he
handling all of this do you have any
contact with him
aaron uh no sir i haven't i haven't
really talked to him
um i mean we'll we'll communicate here
and there but it's just hey how you
doing
um just kind of checking up on each
other not so much about
hey did you see what was going on or no
not
too much like that is just uh checking
up on them outside of football
so how many people are are asking you
the questions that i'm asking you in
your life
aaron uh a lot a lot
i imagine you know and i you know look
it's not like you know you're gonna
break you know any news here but
you know this is a very frayed time
correct for
for packers fans and people in your life
wanting to know
if the gang can be run back together or
if
whatever pieces have fallen apart can be
put back together what is what is your
sense of things on that
just you know knowing whatever you do
know and whatever feelings you may have
on the subject matter um definitely i
mean you know everybody
who's asked uh who's curious you know
um we all want a rod back in green bay i
think that's
that's obvious um he's a great leader a
great player
and a great person off the field just
somebody to learn from
um he he probably believes in you more
than you believe in yourself when you're
first coming in and
uh he just helped players develop so i
mean i i love having him i love having
him around now
he continues my quarterback i think i i
think you've you've mentioned this
before but
i'll i'll i'll ask it again here um
certainly since you just mentioned that
what do you mean by
he believes in you maybe more than you
believe in yourself what do you mean by
that
uh just you know players coming in like
as rookies you know you're
it's bright eyed is is new to you
uh you men everybody may not believe
themselves but you have
a a future hall of famer a
guy who just won the mvp um in your
corner and he's telling you hey
i'm you're one of my uh i'm one of your
biggest fans in this organization and
he tells you that he's he's obviously a
fan because he's seen what you
what you can do and what you bring to
the table and just got to continue to
work so
uh i mean that's part of it right there
not
not just me but i've seen them do it to
so many other other players uh
pick them up or as rookies you know just
bring them along and
guide them along and then they they end
up being great players
does and does he do that for jordan love
too aaron oh yes
oh yes you see him working with jordan
uh every day
all day trying to teach him teach him as
much as he can
and um so that that's the cool part to
see about a-rod you know
can you what what give me an example of
that like you you see him
off to the side giving jordan love
tips and things like that yes sir maybe
it might be a play and uh
what he saw if it was like if it was
like the first reader second
third read maybe what he saw or um
you know or maybe a little bit on the
mechanic side of it or
um it just goes into so many things so
many different things or it could be
uh the sound at the uh at the cadence
trying to catch them
jumping off sides little things so so
many things and
he's just trying to um better the
players around him
truly so what the hell's going on aaron
jones
what is what is happening you i i
i have no clue oh it's right it's about
to say so i guess so what is your before
we put a pin in this and i'll i want to
hit you on the schedule as well here
aaron jones on the rich eisen show
what's your sense do you think week one
when you're in new orleans you're going
to be
grabbing a ball from 12. he's going to
turn around he's going to hand it to you
and off you go
like like like nothing happened or what
do you think what's your sense of it
um i mean i hope i hope so this
i mean that's my quarterback that's our
quarterback uh
so i would i would hope so um i mean
yeah that's all that's all i could think
of you know i hope he's our court like
like i said i hope he's our quarterback
hope he's there week one
uh handing it off and
it all works out yeah you almost sounded
like your coach right there can't wrap
your mind around the concept of him not
being there
that's what you said it's just tough
it's just tough
yeah no so let's talk about your your
schedule here
uh when you grabbed it when you first
saw it what do you look for
or are you what what what do you start
combing your schedule to look for when
you first grab one as a pro bowl
running back aaron jones uh
i i just look and see how many games are
late in lambeau
you're thinking cold weather is that
what you're saying is what you're
thinking
yes see if we get the code
see if we're at lambeau early on in the
season or
later on in the season you know it's
usually one of the other you get
more the home games at the beginning of
the season or more at the end
so just just checking for that and um
i mean i kind of knew i kind of knew
before how i guess how the season kind
of works
um a little bit so i'm glad we
get to play some of the top teams you
know so
what do you think of the fact that six
of your
first nine are on the road and there's a
lot of home games in lambeau in december
and january
what do you think about that aaron jones
uh let's play ball i mean
[Laughter]
get the suitcases ready the first the
first couple of weeks and right
um unpack them at the end and um
welcome to the cold weather welcome to
what we like in lambo
merry christmas too to the browns
christmas day christmas
late afternoon um right in the middle of
the afternoon 3
30 kick around packers i didn't see that
one
yes sir merry christmas i've never
played on christmas i don't think
you're about to sir let's go
that's happening that's pretty cool and
that's the only game that day
that's it there is the rest of the
schedule is coming up on
yes sir well 3 30 in the afternoon on
that day
christmas day let me make sure i'm i'm i
saw it last night my god i spent three
hours staring at this thing i
but i just want to make sure i'm being
accurate uh no there's another game
there's another game colts at cardinals
you lead into that one
browns and packers whole country
settling in christmas day
for you honestly okay
it's coming up so you like that idea
fantastic
um anything else at the schedule leap
out at you i mean the first four games
are pretty darn
tough you know you're gonna be against
the new orleans saints then monday night
against the lions
uh at the niners on nbc and then home
for the steelers
you got that going on right there what
are your thoughts on the first four
right there you know some good good
quality teams uh
on both sides of the ball so um is
you know best first best and that's what
that's what you want at this level
um and that's what the people pay for
and so now it's just trying
time to buckle it up and play and okay
i'm ready
i love it hey aaron thanks for the time
and i appreciate you
saying yes to coming on here because you
know i'm i was going to pepper you with
questions about
aaron rodgers and uh you know and i i i
know it's so
um dicey potentially that you don't want
to be
come across as speaking for him um
but you know what i'm saying exactly but
you know
you are a guy who who who's been in that
locker room and who may have
already sensed anything was it let's
last question for you was there any
sense that something was building to
this point
last year uh no sir it was
actually kind of i mean i think i
woke up in my my mom and my sister
brother if somebody
asked me did i re did i see that article
that
was released or something so i was like
they caught me out of the blue as well
so
the whole sense of of what was reported
on draft day that
that the fact that the fact that he's
told people that
the report that he's told people he
doesn't want to ever play for the
packers again that caught
you had no that you didn't even see
anything like that coming
at all oh no sorry not at all
aaron thanks for the time really
appreciate it always do
um let's do this again during the summer
and if uh the pandemic allows it
you're ever out here in la you know uh
you know the route to the to the studio
i'd love to have you here
yes sir thank you thank you for having
me again right back at you that's aaron
jones of the green bay packers here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here